do facts make good stories facts are
tricky so I think the hardest stories to
break are ones that are based on
real-life events and I have a philosophy
a little bit with my students and
clients that I tell them when it comes
to research I say Wikipedia it and be
done the more you know sometimes is is a
problem actually now that's gonna work
with some stories better than others you
know you you can have a lot more freedom
if you're gonna write if you're writing
about William Wallace where there are
very few written records at that time
and you could have an enormous amount of
freedom and and with something like
Braveheart because we knew virtually
very little about the man versus if
you're gonna do a story about a you know
about Elton John you know someone who's
actually you know in the whose living
and whose facts a lot of us know you're
gonna you're gonna have to you can't
have as much leeway necessarily so it is
harder to make true life stories work as
stories because again remember life is a
situation life itself is not a story so
you're gonna have to find ways to
structure things and for maximum impact
in order to tell a story
I had a experience once where I was a
party and a student introduced me to a
prominent documentary filmmaker who I
won't name okay and and when and she
introduced me and you know as her
screenwriting teacher and the author of
this book that's about screenwriting
story structure and his attitude was a
little bit like yeah structure schmuck
sure
and I said him you know well let me
understand you you know when you make
your documentary films are they just to
our interviews with no cuts at all do
you employ editing do you have cuts and
it's like yeah of course I was like okay
well if you employ editing if you have
cuts you're using structure that's all
structure is structure is about choosing
what events you show in the order that
you show them in and what events you
don't show that's all it is so we can
manipulate real-life events to an extent
and that's what we're gonna have to do
unless you wanted to show a two-hour
interview up with absolutely no cuts if
you know you are if your documentary
film is telling story you're gonna have
to have cuts and you're gonna have to
choose which moment to show on which
omens you cut away from and and which
moments you don't show some true life
events are more easily can be made into
stories than others some it's going to
be very difficult so I can't promise
when people you know come in and they're
doing something on a biographical figure
that it's necessarily gonna work and
sometimes you know I can sympathize with
them the trouble but if we can't find
certain patterns and some some some
people's lives it's it dramatically may
not make for a good story unfortunately
but the less we know about them the
better because then we can make up more
or we can be more you know the less that
there are living figures involved and we
can speculate about for example what the
protagonists flaw was and you know it
doesn't mean that we're radically
changing from the truth but if it's not
a figure we know so much about we can be
a little more flexible about choosing
the elements that most enhance the
real-life events in order to to show a
pattern that could show a story when you
explain some of that to the filmmaker
what was their response
I get a little of this but I wonder for
maybe it stayed with them we'll see
you